and it feels like there's kind of two
buckets right here right there's people
who are worried about surviving through
this and obviously then the cash
business there and it's gonna dictate a
lot of that and then there's others that
are kind of did the hard work already
they did the discipline things and the
good times they've got strong balance
sheets and they're actually getting
aggressive now they're gonna go steal
market share when others are acting yeah
if you're in a good spot right I mean
there's some companies that are doing
well you know some companies that are
doing decent and I'm telling you know
those dive invested in ramp it up right
because the cost per clicks the cost per
customer acquisition have gone way down
you know YouTube prices Facebook prices
Google the you know across the board
Twitter they've all just dropped like a
rock and so if you can afford to go
after and you have a vision for what
your company is gonna be like right
because you gotta know a 2.0 what your
what what you're all about where you're
making your money and how you're going
to do it so if you have that confident
to your product and your service go go
go go put the pedal to the metal and
don't stop to get we're attitude yeah
you keep mentioning kind of America 2.0
maybe elaborate thing what exactly does
that look like in your mind is this an
acceleration of trends that were already
underway is there other things that
change like a lot of respects yeah the
things that you know the things that
caught people's attention before are you
know now are just right in your face you
know how do you treat your employees
what's your brand represent how do you
treat your customers you know how do
your customers brand themselves and how
did you fit into that so those are all
elements of 2.0 but again if there's
something that you think could be better
if there's a better product if there's a
better service what is right you know
I'm all about robotics and precision
medicine and artificial intelligence you
know what is it that I can do there
I'm about you know when we create
medicines in this country you know we
typically have them manufactured
overseas and there are a lot of problems
with them being counterfeit not being as
pure as they're supposed to be and that
created all kinds of illnesses and
challenges you know so we had already
started creating some companies to
address that you know how can I
accelerate those companies like no duh
AI or IO rather that you know for
artificial intelligence the big
companies the fangs the googles the
Netflix the Amazons they already have
that cold right they're investing
billions thousands a
engineers and they're pushing that
envelope all the small to middle sized
companies they typically don't even
understand AI and so we're we're gonna
walk into America 2.0 with a lot of
haves and have-nots the big companies
are going to know how to go to work and
put their their balance sheets to work
the little companies are going to have
to try to figure out how and where they
fit with AI and new technologies and so
you know if you've got a vision of how
to put these new tech technologies to
work and something you think should be
just dratted different and you just got
to go for it and so I think there's
gonna be a lot of great companies
created what's it's all gonna look like
when it's all said and done I don't know
but that's the opportunity right you
know that's why I'm trying to just
visualize where do I see it what do I
think I need to do how can I help how
can I change the game and you know and
just be agile yeah I think a lot of
people are kind of gravitated towards
you on Shark Tank because you really
hammer home like this idea of the
American spirit and entrepreneurship and
innovation that's like built what we
have today right it's built the greatest
country in the world it feels like in
times of crisis kind of the saying if
there's no capitalist in a crisis right
we get more towards the the other end of
the spectrum maybe talk a little bit
about like how do we ensure that we keep
true to the roots of innovation and not
ingenuity and entrepreneurship and kind
of use the American spirit to come out
of this that's who we are right that's
in our DNA that's what makes this
different than any other country on the
planet you know I mean you don't see you
know countries built around
entrepreneurship like you see in the
United States of America right they
don't talk about the French dream or the
Iranian dream right we talk about the
American dream and that's why you see so
many people come to this country even
when you look at some of the greatest
companies created over the last 20 years
they were started by immigrants who came
here knowing that this was the best
country in the world to start a business
that's not gonna change but you know you
have to pay attention to what's
happening you have to understand context
you know Bernie Sanders didn't have a
movement for no reason right there are a
lot of people who question capitalism
there are a lot of people who want
stronger rights for workers and
deservedly so there's a lot of people
who rightfully want a higher minimum
wage you know there's I went back for
some of my for my companies that that I
run and
the question are any of my employees
getting government assistance because to
me that's the ultimate socialism when
I'm taking money when my employees are
taking money from the government because
I'm not paying them enough and so I
wanted to rectify that
and so you know for capitalism to
continue to thrive when we come out of
this it's gonna have to be a lot more
compassionate you're gonna have to put
employees first you're gonna have to put
shareholders last you know and that's
gonna be good for business because how
you treat your employees and customers
is how your brand is going to be defined
forever you know your people are not
gonna want to be associated with a
company who just who had money in the
bank it just ditched all their employees
you know and even if your backs against
the wall and your company was broke and
you had to lay or furlough or fire
everybody
if you communicated with them and we're
honest and transparent then people will
understand that because you as an
entrepreneur or CEO you're getting
crushed just as bad you know and and so
everybody's in the same boat but you
know how you do things now if you don't
show compassion if you're not nice if
you're not understanding if you don't
offer equity to employees as an example
you don't recognize you're gonna have to
pay people more to keep them um then
you're you're gonna be challenged yeah
and we see this before right I mean
companies that I've seen a strong
culture have took care of their
employees they've always you know tended
to do well people really write books
about it because it's so rare and now I
think what you're basically saying is
hey everyone's gonna have to start to
put this as a core tenet of what they're
building without question I mean look
every single person who's on social
media which is pretty much everybody 40
and under right you know if not older
another you know that's our brand what
we put on social media is who we are and
it's what we want everybody to see about
us and the products that we discussed
the products that we show on our
pictures you know the things that we say
and do those all represent who we are
and if you're not a product that has a
good culture that if you you don't you
know think of more than just the bottom
line people aren't going to connect you
people aren't gonna get behind you and
you're not gonna have a company you're
not gonna have a business you're gonna
be gone so the bigger picture is
capitalism has to be compassionate but
that's good business yeah